[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Professor
Wu is the author
of "Yellow: Race in America,
Beyond Black and White,"
and co-author of "Race,
Rights, and Reparation:
Law and the Japanese-American
Internment."
And prior to his
academic career,
he held a clerkship with the
late US district Judge Frank J.
Battisti in Cleveland,
and practiced law
with the firm of Morrison and
Foerster in San Francisco.
And while there, he
devoted a quarter
of his time to pro bono work
on behalf of indigent clients.
So it is my pleasure to give a
warm welcome to Professor Frank
H. Wu.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANK H. WU: Good afternoon.
Delighted to be here
with you talking
about issues of race,
diversity, the changing
face of our nation--
some of the subjects that
are most fraught, most tense
in this anxious era of ours.
I hope to provoke you
to think for yourselves,
not persuade you
to think as I do,
to think about these issues
with a new perspective, one
that you haven't heard before.
I'll be talking to you today
about the model minority myth.
Even if you haven't
heard that term before,
I'm confident that you
know the stereotype.
That's what it is.
It's an image, one of
the predominant images
of people of Asian descent,
east and south, here in the US.
It's the image that we're all
whiz-kid rocket scientist child
prodigies.
It's the idea that I must have
graduated from high school
when I was 10, from college
by the time I was 12,
with perfect SAT
scores, and so on.
It's the idea that I learned to
play the violin at an early age
before I even started
kindergarten, and then
the piano.
And by the time I
was a youngster,
I was playing the violin at
Carnegie Hall or the piano,
or maybe I was playing
the violin and piano
simultaneously.
It's the notion that I can
do calculus in my head.
It's this idea that our
parents arrived here penniless
strangers from another
shore, that if we
got an A-minus on a report
card, we were beaten.
It's the diligent, up
by your own bootstraps
myth with a Confucian twist,
with a slightly different look
to it.
And what I'd like to do is
debunk this model minority
myth, explain why, like
every racial stereotype,
it's dangerous, even though on
the surface it seems positive.
After all, we don't want
to just be politically
correct or hypersensitive.
If someone says, you're
smart, you're hardworking,
how could we possibly object?
People sometimes say to me.
What's wrong with you?
We're trying to pay
you a compliment.
So being a lawyer and a law
professor, whenever I talk,
I have a caveat, a disclaimer.
And so my caveat and
my disclaimer is this--
there's nothing wrong with
being smart and hardworking.
We should applaud that.
We should encourage it.
It's wonderful to
see people invest
in higher education,
to take seriously
that they can improve their
lot in lives, to be dedicated,
disciplined.
All of that is commendable.
And I don't want anyone
to think that for a moment
I would take anything away from
my parents, or your parents,
or grandparents, those who
achieved phenomenal success.
I look to them with
so much respect.
I literally would not be here
if my parents hadn't come here
to the US and met here.
And then I wouldn't have
done any of the things
that you've heard
from my background
if they hadn't set high
standards and encouraged me.
So I want to be clear--
to be smart, to be hardworking,
those are commendable traits.
That's what we should encourage
everyone to aspire to.
My concern is different.
My concern is when
Asian-Americans
are portrayed as somehow
racially smart and hardworking,
as if they have an
oriental secret, as
if it's something
that's unique to them
genetically or culturally.
That's what worries me.
And I'd like to take some time
to explain to you why this is
so troubling, concerning, how
it shows that we've fallen short
on a promise that we've made
to each other here in the New
World, in a diverse
democracy, an experiment
in self-governance--
that we will break free from
these racial stereotypes.
We will allow people to write
the scripts of their own lives,
to chart their own destinies.
And also being a law
professor, I always
usually make three points.
So I'm going to
make three points.
The first is that the
model minority myth
is inaccurate on its own terms.
It's misleading.
Second, that it leads to
resentment and prejudice,
discrimination, backlash.
And third and finally, that
it's a form of false flattery.
It's not really actually
about Asian-Americans at all.
I'd like to suggest it's a
none-too-subtle way of sending
an insult to other
people of color.
Let me start first, though,
with the point that, just as
a factual matter--
it doesn't matter
who you are, it
doesn't matter what
your politics are--
that the model minority
myth has, at its core,
a misleading falsehood.
And the misleading falsehood is
it fails to take into account
that Asian-Americans, being
predominantly foreign born,
are like others who
are foreign born--
that is, they're brain drain.
They're cream of the crop.
It's no surprise that
people coming from Asia
are so successful, and that
their US-born descendants are,
because they represent
the individuals who
had achieved the most
in their home countries
before they migrated.
They had human capital
or actual capital.
That is to say, my
parents came here
to go to graduate
school on scholarships.
That's true, probably,
of many of your parents
or grandparents, maybe even
some of you in this room.
It means that the
individuals coming here,
they're not representative.
And to be able to migrate
from Asia is not easy.
It requires, for many people,
that they migrate within Asia
from the distant provinces
to a coastal big city,
and then that they
have that opportunity
to obtain a coveted
green card, often
by showing they have
superior skills.
So the model minority myth
is based on a skewed sample.
And many of you here
have STEM backgrounds.
You're familiar with how to
think about these issues.
So statistically, the people
who are our ancestors, those
of us who are
Asian-American, are not
like the people
they left behind.
They tend to have had
higher levels of education,
higher levels of wealth,
greater access to this chance
to cross the ocean and
to make a new home here.
So because Asian-Americans
represent brain drain,
right away you're starting
from a beginning point
where the comparison is inapt.
If you look at people
who are foreign born
of all ethnic backgrounds,
and compare them
to people who are native born
of the same ethnic background,
there tend to be
marked differences.
In fact, ironically,
some of the studies
suggest that
Asian-Americans whose
families have been here
multiple generations
regressed to the norm.
That is, they look more and more
American by the time they reach
the third generation, fourth
generation, fifth generation,
in everything from how
much schooling they
have to even rates of
heart disease, and so on.
If you live here long enough,
if your family is here
long enough, you do get bigger.
That is, we are taller
than our cousins overseas.
But we also suffer from all
the negative consequences
of fast food and the diet
that you usually have access
to here, so higher levels of
hypertension, heart disease,
and so on.
So my first point is
that the model minority
myth, if you just
want to be factual,
and there's also the
problem of generalizing
about race and ethnicity,
these artificial categories
that we've created that
have tragic histories that
are so often used for
invidious purposes.
But even if we accept
that it's OK to compare
different communities
against each other,
the problem with this
comparison, this model minority
myth, is that it's
based on a myth.
It's based on this idea
that everyone who comes here
is literally
penniless, with nothing
but the shirts on their backs.
Now, even if they came with
only a suitcase and very little,
they came with a scholarship.
They came with admission
to graduate school
at Stanford or wherever else.
That by itself,
that opportunity,
shows that they have something
that others don't have,
including native-born
Asian-Americans.
So that's the first point.
The second, though, is that
the model minority myth
generates its own problems.
When I was a kid
growing up in Detroit
in the 1970s, my parents, they
socialized with other people
like them--
Chinese who come via Taiwan.
And my mother would
often say to me,
why can't you be
like so-and-so's son?
And she would compare me to
some kid who I sort of knew
from the dinner parties
that our parents had,
who had gotten an SAT score
just slightly better than mine.
And you know what would happen
when my mother would compare me
with some kid who was the
child of a friend of hers?
I'd want to go over and
punch that kid in the nose.
Now, that reaction,
I think, is normal.
It doesn't show that I
was especially violent.
That's what
everybody wants to do
when they're compared this way.
Actually, a number
of recent studies
have come out done by
social scientists that
show that in a
workplace setting,
even in an enlightened workplace
setting where people are
educated, they're
civilized, they're decent,
they think of themselves as
colleagues-- in a workplace
setting, the people who are
recognized as overachievers
tend to be undermined
by coworkers.
That is, we all, to a little
extent live up to or down
to the saying Gore Vidal had.
He once said, "Every
time a friend of mine
succeeds, a little
part of me dies."
So we all have this
competitive streak in us.
And when people are held up--
this is a nation that
celebrates the underdog.
We want to see people
succeed who come from behind,
whether that's in sports
or in any other context.
So the model minority myth, by
suggesting that Asian-Americans
are uniformly overachievers--
just think about that term.
What does it mean
to overachieve?
It means to have gotten
more than your fair share,
more than what others expected.
To be an overachiever is to put
a target on your back, to say,
this is somebody, and
part of a community, that
is disproportionately
represented
among the engineers.
This is a group that
we should resent,
because somehow they've
done a little too well.
For Asian-Americans
in particular,
there's a long history
of this sentiment,
as Ronald Takaki, the leading
scholar of the subject pointed
out, Asian-Americans
have long been punished,
not for their vices,
but for their virtues.
So the model minority
myth is not new.
If you go back to the era of
the Chinese Exclusion Act,
so in 1882, Congress started
to regulate the borders.
And the first time they had
done that in a comprehensive way
was to exclude people on the
basis of ethnic backgrounds,
specifically Chinese,
and then all Asians.
There was an Asiatic barred zone
for a couple of generations.
And people of Asian descent,
even if they came legally,
could not naturalize.
There was a color line, a bar.
You had to show you
were a free white person
or of African
nativity or descent
to naturalize and become a
member of the body politic.
If you go back and
study the movement which
started in California,
right in San Francisco,
to keep out people
of Chinese descent,
do you know what
it was based on?
The model minority myth.
It was based on the claim that
Chinese workers, the people who
built the Transcontinental
Railroad, for example,
almost the entire
workforce that laid
the Western half of the tracks
consisted of Chinese men,
10,000 to 12,000, and the
railroad barons, who competed,
actually bet who
could lay more track
in a day, the Chinese
coming from the west
or the Irish coming
from the east.
You know that term,
"chinaman's chance?"
It comes from that era.
Because the Chinese
were assigned tasks
that no one else wanted to do--
lowered in baskets to
dynamite mountainsides
where they might not survive.
That's where that
term comes from.
They worked so
hard, yet they were
excluded from the ceremony,
when the golden spike was driven
at Promontory Point in Utah,
to unite in manifest destiny
this great continent of ours.
Well, after the
railroad was built,
and Chinese migrated, many
of them to San Francisco,
there was a recession.
And the Chinese were
looked at, and thought of,
as working too hard,
as too successful.
The main premise
for the exclusion
was that white working men, many
of them themselves immigrants,
foreigners-- so this
wasn't about natives
versus foreigners, it was
about whites versus Asians--
the claim that was made
was that whites could not
compete against Asians.
Samuel Gompers, a renowned
labor leader, wrote a pamphlet.
He was a union man, and
really progressive, liberal,
renowned--
but anti-Chinese.
He wrote a pamphlet
in the early 1900s.
And when I give speeches--
those of you, it's
sort of ironic
that I say this here on your
campus-- when I give speeches,
I always say to people,
"Don't take my word for it,
Google this."
So go ahead and pull out
your phone and look this up.
Samuel Gompers, he
wrote a pamphlet back
when that's how you
made your points,
called, "Meat versus Rice."
That's the actual
name of this pamphlet.
And it was one of
the leading documents
arguing for the exclusion.
And its argument-- he went
on for pages making this
argument-- his argument
was as follows--
white working men-- he was
only talking about men--
have to eat meat.
They can't survive without meat.
Whereas the Asiatic, the
oriental, the Mongoloid,
they can subsist on rice.
So he argued this is unfair.
White people need meat.
They need lots of meat.
Asian people eat rice.
Whites will lose to Asians
in this economic competition.
That's a early version of
the model minority myth--
the Asians work too hard.
So his conclusion
was, the only response
is to keep out the Chinese
and eventually all the Asians,
because that's the
fair way to do things,
to draw this racial line.
So this sort of resentment
persists to this day.
And the model minority
myth, like all
of the racial stereotypes,
can be turned on its head.
It can be flipped around.
Let me explain how
this happens, so that
what looks positive
one day becomes
very negative the next day.
What is it to be hardworking?
It's to be, as Gompers portrayed
it, unfair competition.
What is it to be smart?
It's to be a geek, a nerd,
to just have book knowledge,
to not be practical.
What is it even to be
good at math and science?
It's to lack people
skills, to not have
soul, to not be a leader.
People sometimes
say to me, would you
help me fix my laptop?
You Asians are all so good
at that sort of thing.
Makes you want to go right over
and wipe out their hard drive.
Not to be perverse, but
because that's a stereotype,
and it's a stereotype that's
extended to so many fields,
even the ones where
Asian-Americans are thought
of as successful or dominating.
Think about classical
music, for example.
Where would Western
classical music
be if it weren't for Asian
and Asian-American audiences
and performers?
You wouldn't have classical
music at this point.
But what is it they say
about the Asian prodigy
pianist or violinist?
They always say, technical
perfection, but no
soul, no character.
So the very positive trait of
playing the notes perfectly
is held against you, as if
you're an automaton, a robot.
It's mechanical.
You're not really a human being.
You can't experience
the fullness of life.
It's this idea that
Asian-Americans all look alike,
that we're humorless,
we can't be
differentiated from each other.
Worse than that, the
model minority myth
generates resentment.
How does it do that?
Well, this is a moment
when we in America,
both within the nation and as
we look at the global stage,
have an acute sense of anxiety.
And Asian-Americans represent
both the rise of the East
and the decline of
the West to those
who would portray an
inevitable clash among people
on the basis of color of skin,
texture of hair, shape of eye.
That's not the way
I see the world.
But there are those who
believe that we are headed
for this battle among races.
And in that, they portray
Asians and Asian-Americans
simultaneously with respect--
they're doing so well--
but with resentment--
they're doing too well.
It's what motivates quotas
in higher education and so
much more, this notion
of invasion, of takeover.
You've heard people say when
they go to a high school
graduation, and
the valedictorian,
and the entire
rest of the top 10
are named Nguyen,
Patel, Kim, and so on.
They say, we're
the real Americans.
How come Asians are
winning the science
fairs, the spelling bees?
They're getting all the
scholarships, all the prizes.
And so this model minority
myth, which has a germ of truth,
as so many stereotypes do--
it gets exaggerated,
and distorted,
and turned into a
threat, into the sense
that if you're not
Asian, if you're white,
you shouldn't take AP
calculus or a science class,
because the Asians will
set too hard of a curve.
You hear that, here in
this area, in the suburbs.
As white families say,
we can't do as well,
and therefore, we have to have
preferences to favor whites,
not because of any bias
that they might face,
but because of this sense that
the Asians are taking over.
So that's my second point, that
the model minority myth is too
easily abused and then
Asian-Americans too
easily abused, that even
though on the surface,
it seems superficially positive,
that lurking underneath is
this sense of racial resentment,
and that it provokes that,
it stokes that, because
of this sense built
into it of racial competition.
Third and finally, though,
the model minority myth
sometimes isn't even really
about Asian-Americans.
If you go back to where it
was first published in 1967,
in "The New York Times,"
in the "Sunday Magazine,"
there was a sociologist,
William Petersen,
he wrote what has been called
the single most influential
article ever written
about Asian-Americans.
You can still find this.
It's not hard to Google.
It's called "Success Story,
Japanese-American Style."
And it's a
sympathetic portrayal.
This is one generation
after World War II.
Japanese-Americans had
been locked up, interned,
imprisoned without due
process, 120,000 people,
2/3 of them citizens
of this nation
because as the Commander of
the Western Defense said,
A Jap's a Jap and that's
all there is to it.
Because they were deemed
to be enemy aliens,
even if they were
assimilated, English speaking,
had never been to Tokyo,
men, women, children,
the elderly, disabled,
all of them locked up.
So in 1967, Petersen
wrote a lavish article
that had all these photographs.
And it was about how
Japanese-Americans had made
it--
how after the war had
ended, the camps had closed,
how they had overcome the
bias, and they were successful.
They were out-competing whites.
So if you looked at
their income levels
and so on, by objective
measures, you might say,
wow, this is an ethnic group
that is at the top of the heap,
although there, too,
just as with brain drain,
family income levels
are highly misleading.
Asian-Americans tend to have
higher levels of education.
Once you control for
that, once you control
for geographic concentration
in high income areas,
multiple generations
contributing
to household income,
Asian-Americans actually,
once all that is controlled
for, fare less well.
But that's a different point.
In Petersen's article, he
extolled all the virtues
of Japanese-Americans.
But there was a catch.
It was to point out the
vices of African-Americans
and Hispanics.
Now, I'm not
interpreting anything.
I'm not inferring.
He made it explicit, because
the first half of his article
was all about people of
Japanese descent here in the US,
and how great they were.
The back half of his
article was, and he said--
I'm paraphrasing, but this
is roughly what he said,
he transitioned, he
said, this example
stands in contrast to what
might be called the problem
minorities.
And he used Japanese-Americans
as an example.
The real point of
his article was
to say that if you looked at
blacks and Hispanics, Negroes
and Mexicans in the
terms of the day,
that whatever
measurement you use,
they didn't compare as
well when you set them
against Japanese-Americans.
So he looked at
juvenile delinquency.
He looked at income.
He looked at various
measurements.
And that's been a
consistent theme.
Asian-Americans
often are held up,
and it's good that we talk about
race beyond black and white.
That's the theme of
the book that I wrote.
It's not so good
when Asian-Americans
are brought into the picture not
to build bridges, but to divide
and conquer, using a
longstanding tactic to use
Asian-Americans as a wedge
group to say, in a none
too subtle manner,
look at the Asians.
They've made it, why can't you?
That's the concern that I
have about the model minority
myth at the end of
the day, that really,
far from being a compliment
of Asian-Americans,
it's an insult of
other people of color.
You know, this Asian-American
example is not unique.
There are other
positive stereotypes
that, when you think about
it, they're troubling.
I'll give you a few examples.
So you still sometimes hear
people say something such
as, oh, Jews, they're
really good at making money.
Now, on the surface, that's
a positive statement, right?
Who wouldn't want to be
good at making money?
But when you think
about it, it fits
with anti-Semitic
traditions of money lending,
and usury, and of global
financial conspiracies.
So if someone said in
casual conversation to you,
oh, Jews, they're good at
making money, you pause.
You wait, because you want
to hear what is said next,
because what is said next
can be very disturbing.
And then it turns out that
the person is not really
admiring at all--
far from it.
You sometimes hear
people say about blacks,
oh, natural athletes.
And then a moment later, they
say, they were bred that way.
And then they suggest
it's all brute strength.
It's brawn, it's not brains.
That's why African-Americans
are good at being
the linebacker, but not
the quarterback, not
the manager or coach.
And so commentators,
sometimes it
slips out as they're talking
about performance on the field.
So even though it sounds
like a compliment--
he's a natural athlete--
it suggests also that that
individual didn't really
put any effort into it, that
they don't deserve credit
for whatever award
they've just won,
that it's not because of
them as an individual.
It's because of them
as a racial group.
So race is so volatile-- we've
had such a history with it--
that we know to
avoid stereotyping.
Yet the model
minority myth seems
to violate all these rules.
It seems to be an
example of a stereotype
that we embrace, where
we're willing to say, oh,
Asians, the model minority, and
then talk about them as if they
should be copied.
I hope that I've shown at
least a few reasons why
we should be skeptical.
I'll conclude by
telling you a story,
and then we'll open
up for dialogue,
because that is at the heart
of this diversity of ours,
this great democracy of ours.
When I was a kid growing
up, if you told me
that you wanted to talk to me
about any of these issues--
race, civil rights, if you
mentioned the model minority
myth, and so on--
I would not have
had any interest.
I was like any other kid.
I just wanted to ride my
bicycle around the block,
fit in, be normal.
We all yearn to
belong in that way.
And the truth is, though I'm
ashamed to admit this now,
I was always a little bit
embarrassed of my parents
and angry with them.
I was embarrassed of them,
because they had accents.
They ate funny foods.
My dad was always trying to
get me to eat chicken feet.
When we watched television,
they didn't quite
laugh at the right time.
If there was a dispute
with the phone company,
they'd need my help
straightening it out
because my language
was better than theirs.
And in that awkward
role reversal,
even though I was a kid, I would
have to be their interpreter
and translator.
No doubt some of
you in this room
have had those experiences.
And I was always a
little angry with them,
because when I would
come home from school,
and I would explain that
yet again, I'd been teased
and taunted, subjected
to the common childhood
cruelty of the playground,
we know now to condemn it
as bullying-- you know, being
called chink and jap and gook,
being asked if I ate dogs,
my parents were communists,
how I could see
with eyes like that,
my parents would scold me.
They would say, you should
try harder to fit in.
And so I always figured that
my parents were blaming me
for all these experiences.
Little did I know.
You see, as a kid, I
was a little naive.
I thought I was smart,
but I was a little naive.
I figured that it was only
as kids that we face this.
I wanted to be like my dad.
I wanted to grow up, wear a
coat and tie, shave, drive,
go off to work, because I
figured once you're an adult,
you didn't face any
of these issues.
Little did I know, of course,
my father and my mother,
they faced all of the same
when they went off to work,
or if they went to the
bank to take out a loan,
or if they were shopping.
They shielded my brothers
and me from all of this.
And my parents, they
didn't blame me.
They blamed themselves.
You see, they figured
that so strongly did
they believe in the
American dream that beckoned
the world over, promising
that San Francisco had
a gold mountain, that this was
a place of hope and opportunity,
as it is--
I say all this as
an optimist, as I
believe in the same dream--
my parents didn't understand
that we wouldn't just
be accepted, that
what they faced,
what my brothers and I faced,
that it was because we had
fallen short on the principles
that we as a nation espouse,
that this was racial
discrimination.
They didn't have the
language for that.
They didn't speak the
language of civil rights,
because they literally
spoke another language.
And I didn't speak the
language of civil rights,
because I was a kid.
And so we didn't
quite understand
what was happening when
we faced all of this.
And so it was only much
later when I was mature
that I came to understand
how much my parents had
internalized, how they figured
it was their own fault.
You see, they thought it was
because they were what others
perceived of them as being--
foreigners.
Although I admire
them so much, they
did something I could not do.
They traveled halfway
around the world,
resettled, put down new roots,
achieved middle-class status,
raised a family,
prospered, eventually
became Asian-Americans.
But back then, we didn't quite
understand what was happening.
And my parents always
wanted me to be an engineer,
a scientist, maybe a doctor.
When I was 40 years old,
my mother said to me,
it's not too late.
You can still go
to medical school.
And I was resentful
about that, too.
But what I later realized
is that my parents
had learned a lesson.
They never articulated
it quite this way,
but they figured that
in law, in the fields
that I've chosen to pursue,
giving speeches, writing,
that all depends on language.
It depends on culture.
It depends on understanding and
fitting in, in a way that they
couldn't.
So they thought-- and
this they did say--
if you use numbers,
you'll do well.
People can't judge you.
Then it's not about
your identity.
It's not about where your
grandparents came from.
You can have an accent,
because the numbers
are numbers in any
language, in any culture.
And you'll be better off in
what we now call a STEM field.
What they didn't know,
and what I didn't know,
but what the statistics bear
out is even in STEM fields,
Asian-Americans face
a glass ceiling,
or what's been called
a bamboo ceiling,
so that when you look
at so many workplaces--
I'm astonished-- not just in
tech, but in accounting firms,
law firms, Asian-Americans now
have decent representation,
even arguably, for some ethnic
groups, over-representation
at the entry level.
But once you get to
managers, once you
get to people in
charge, once you
get to people who are
leading that company,
unless they were the
entrepreneurs who founded it,
you find hardly any
Asian-Americans,
even in technical fields
where at the lower ranks,
they're the predominant group.
Why is this?
Well, I would suggest
to you that it
has to do with the prejudice
of the model minority myth.
This is how it
comes full circle.
Because what is it
that the model minority
myth tells other people?
It tells them that
what we do is numbers.
what we don't do
is interact well with
other human beings.
We don't have the character,
the soul, the people skills.
We're not funny.
It constrains, in
the eyes of others
and, perhaps, in our
own self-perception,
the range of activities that
Asian-Americans engage in
and that they are successful at.
We are denied the fullness
of the human experience.
Now, if people are engineers,
as most of you in this room are,
that's good.
That's wonderful.
But if all Asian-Americans
are only engineers,
if that's all they
can pursue, if none
can be artists or
athletes, it is not
only that stereotype
is fulfilled.
It is that some individuals are
denied the dream that they have
that doesn't conform
with the image
that everyone else
is carrying around.
Now, all of this
also, it doesn't
have to be in your face,
egregious, overt, explicit.
Though I wrote a
book called "Yellow,"
with a bright yellow cover to
make the argument that race was
not literally black and
white, I actually wanted
to give the book
the title, "Gray,"
and have a dull, drab cover.
The publisher would
never go for that.
They thought yellow
was going to sell.
A book called "Gray"
would just puzzle people.
But it's because I wanted
to make another point--
that race is also not
figuratively, metaphorically,
symbolically black and white.
We often talk about it
that way, as if it's only
about villains and victims.
It's about the KKK,
skinheads, neo-Nazis,
those who would commit violence,
who would shoot, or stab,
or spit upon someone,
deny them a job or a home,
or seat them when they went
out to eat, and those to whom
those wrongs are done,
upon whose bodies violence
is visited, who are
powerless, weak, passive, not
agents of their own destiny.
And there are villains and
victims, not just in the past,
not just in the deep
South or some other place,
but here and now.
And I'm dedicated to fighting
villains and helping victims.
But I wonder, if we
frame the story that way,
which we so often do-- that's
the conventional narrative-- it
is one of progress.
It is triumphalist.
It is, we have overcome
these problems.
We teach our children
not to use the n-word.
We're post racial.
People said that until about a
year ago, the sense that race
is framed in this stark manner.
I wonder if it allows us too
easily to say to ourselves,
well, I'm not a villain.
I'm not a victim, either.
So I wash my hands
of this matter--
to be able to say that
we are not complicit.
What I'd like to suggest is
sometimes, this is ambiguous.
It's complicated.
It isn't a case where
you find the smoking
gun, where you can say,
that person there, they're
the wrongdoer.
They're the one who
espouses hatred.
If we just fire them,
all will be well.
Sometimes in workplaces and
neighborhoods that we live in,
in society as a whole, the
villain has long since died,
or they can't be easily
identified, that culprit.
They fled the scene.
Yet we still have the
lingering problems.
They're structural.
They're the burden of
history that we share.
And they're the
microaggressions.
Even what seems to be
a compliment conceals
and signals.
It shows us something about
what's beneath the surface.
For Asian-Americans
it's, where are you from?
I say, Detroit.
People furrow their brows,
and say, no, no, no, no.
They get annoyed.
Where are you really from--
a question we ask only of
some people selectively.
I know I've asked white people,
where are you really from?
And they get flustered.
And they say, well,
I'm an American.
I'm from Iowa, which
is exactly the point.
They're assured
of their identity,
even as they doubt mine.
And it's also to
say I am a liar.
I can't be from the Midwest--
after all, just look at me.
It's to say that I
have no privacy--
that I must disclose
my ethnicity,
and then sing and dance in
some way, and offer an egg roll
or be obsequious
like Charlie Chan.
It's to say that we are
always, in the minds of others,
first and foremost orientals,
Asians, the model minority,
the perpetual foreigner.
So it's these moments
when someone says,
I wanted to let you know,
you speak English so well--
they're really quite surprised.
This still happens to
me every now and then.
I always reply, gee, thanks.
So do you.
Because what they're
really saying is,
you don't sound like the image
that I have rattling around
in the back of my head.
You don't sound like you have
an accent, like you belong here.
It's a sense of surprise.
That's how the model
minority myth works.
It's not always open like that.
Sometimes it is,
but sometimes, you
wonder when you interview for
a job, and the questions you're
asked, if maybe the
person talking to you
is just thinking back
fondly to their childhood
and their favorite Bruce
Lee movie or Jackie Chan,
and that's who they see you
as, the martial arts Kung Fu
expert, as the rocket
scientist grown up,
but don't understand that
you're applying to be a lawyer
or for a different job,
not one that emphasizes
the skills that they
would assign to you,
but that is about the strength
you as an individual actually
have.
When we talk about the
model minority myth,
we are able to glimpse
and have an insight
into the complexities of race.
This isn't easy.
Race, when you look here
on this campus, when
you walk around any
selective college,
you realize it doesn't
matter who you are.
And it's not a claim
of ethnic pride.
You realize that race is not
literally black and white,
that people don't fit just
neatly into one of two boxes.
My proposition to you is that
race is also not figuratively
black and white.
It's not just about
the overt instances
where someone discriminates.
It's also about everything
else that we can't quite
put our finger on.
And we wouldn't say in
this case, it's clear cut,
but when you look
at the pattern that
emerges, you can't
help but notice
that all of the Asian-Americans
are concentrated in one area,
even though some would
rather do something else.
And they're all at the bottom.
None has risen, despite having
master's degrees, and PhDs,
and all the training you
could possibly wish for.
And you wonder to yourself,
how did this come to be?
We can do better than that.
That's why all of us, or
our ancestors, however
many generations ago came
here, because they thought
that here in America, we
believed in a set of ideals,
principles that united
us in a civic culture
through the Constitution,
through the Bill of Rights.
It is this notion that we are
the authors of our own destiny.
We write the scripts
that we will follow.
We are not constrained
by stereotypes, the model
minority, or any of the others.
I'm confident that
we will make good
on diversity and
democracy, but only
if we come together,
only if we recognize
these complexities of how
race works at all times,
and yet how each of us
has a stake in making
this community better
than it has been,
of bequeathing to our children
the ideal of the United States
of America.
Thank you so very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm happy to take questions.
We've allocated
about 15 minutes.
I understand some people
are watching remotely.
That's great.
And so I will do something that
law professors are taught never
to do.
I will answer your question.
You see, in law school-- and I
know we have some lawyers here
including a former
student, thank you--
in law school, we just
started school this week,
professors usually say,
that's a good question.
What do you think?
So I won't do that here.
If you ask me a question, I
will give you the best answer
that I possibly can.
And I hope you will challenge
anything and everything
that I have said.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was hoping you could
talk a little bit more
about Southeast
Asian communities?
Because contrary to
your first point,
a lot of Southeast Asians
come to America as refugees.
And they have some of
the highest poverty rates
and the lowest education
rates in America.
And I was wondering
if you could talk
about how the model minority
erases their experiences.
FRANK H. WU: Yes, absolutely.
I really appreciate that point.
Southeast Asians and Pacific
Islanders, for example,
you're celebrating AAPI.
We hardly ever take time to
talk about Pacific Islanders.
And when you look at the data,
if you don't disaggregate it,
it's misleading.
It gives you a picture of the
world that's not accurate.
So I actually--
let me preface this
by explaining why I
wrote the book I wrote.
I wrote the book I wrote
because I started writing a term
paper when I was in college.
I was a sophomore.
And I wanted to write a term
paper about Asian-Americans
and civil rights.
So I went to the library,
went to the card catalog.
Most of you don't remember
the card catalog room.
Google replaced it.
But remember when you
went to this room,
and there were
these huge cabinets
with long drawers
you'd pull out,
and there'd be index cards,
one for every book-- actually,
three for every book, by
title, by author, by subject.
I looked up Asian-Americans
and civil rights.
You know what?
When I went to the library at a
fine East Coast private school,
there were no books.
No one had ever written a
book about Asian-Americans
and civil rights.
And when I went and looked
at the books about race,
there were dozens of
books about race--
thick, thin, by liberals,
conservatives, historians,
sociologists, journalists, old
books, new books, you name it.
Even though the
dust jacket blurbs
said this has the latest
census data, if everyone read
this book, the world
would be a better place--
they touted the virtues
of the authors--
when I read the books, there
weren't any Asian-Americans
in them.
Even though the books
claimed to be universal,
and they had these
grand titles--
this book is comprehensive,
everything about race
is in this book--
I would read.
And in the first
chapter, the author
would say, well, there's
some Asian people.
There are some Hispanics.
But I don't really know
anything about them.
So they're not in this book.
I would be offended, not
as an Asian-American.
I would just be
offended just as someone
who's a student who wanted to
get a good grade on my paper
and who had eyes.
Because I could stroll across
campus and see this book
is wrong.
It's wrong in the sense that
the picture of the world that it
offers us is not accurate.
So that's where I always
begin, that this is not about
are you Asian-American?
You want to claim your
place in the world?
Some of it is about that.
But it doesn't matter
what your ethnicity is,
where your grandparents
came from who you voted for,
what academic discipline
you're in, what public policies
you support.
When we talk about any
issue, we should start
with a picture that's accurate.
And the picture the model
minority myth presents
is not accurate.
And let me turn now very
specifically to your question.
One of the ways
it's not accurate
is because it altogether
omits the experience
of Southeast Asians,
Vietnamese, Cambodian, Hmong.
It omits the experience
of Pacific Islanders.
It omits a whole history
of colonial conquests
the United States has.
And it even omits something very
important about the migration
from places such as
China, Japan, India,
which I'll talk about, too.
But let me address your
very specific question.
You are absolutely right.
When you look at
Southeast Asian groups,
if you want to aggregate, if you
want to look at the averages,
if you want to generalize,
you want to compare,
what do you find?
You find high school dropout
rates, teen pregnancy rates,
income levels equivalent
to blacks and Hispanics.
You find housing segregation.
You find gang violence.
I'm not touting this.
I'm saying we ignore it.
We not only ignore it,
we deny it deliberately.
Because we say, oh, you Asians,
you're all doing so well.
What do we have to
be worried about?
Plus you're a bunch
of foreigners.
Never mind that
these are individuals
who naturalized, that
in many instances,
they fought for
the United States.
That explains why they're here.
Or it's their American-born
children and grandchildren,
who deserve every bit as
much consideration, whatever
program we have.
But Asian-Americans
sometimes are left out
because of the model minority
myth, because people explicitly
say, "You have no problems."
And then they add,
plus, you can always
go back where you came from.
That's the perpetual foreigner
syndrome, a different subject.
You can have me back
to talk about that.
So you've touched upon a
very important point, which
is the model minority
myth also whitewashes
very real racial bias and
racial disparities, including
among Asian-Americans.
There's an additional
point to this, which is--
and this is a very
sophisticated crowd,
so I'm going to talk about
numbers for a moment--
migration from Asia actually
tends to have a bipolar
distribution, so that even if
you take the groups that are
thought of as the
most well-to-do--
so Chinese and South Asians--
and you look at
contemporary migration now,
it has both the people with
PhDs, MDs, the brain drain,
the white--
and there's a huge
segment including
some who are coming
undocumented who
are taxicab drivers, waiters.
These two communities
are very different.
And the first community
would disavow the second.
They wouldn't acknowledge
that actually,
when you talk about people
who are undocumented,
there is a huge Asian
undocumented population.
And when you talk about
the model minority myth,
you're ignoring
urban Chinatowns.
You're ignoring the people
who, when you go out
to eat at your favorite
Chinese buffet,
are making minimum wage or less.
So thank you.
Your point is
absolutely well-taken.
And it's one reason why--
one other reason why--
the model minority
myth is dangerous
and wrong, but also
a reason why when we
have celebrations,
when we have events,
we really have
to be all-inclusive and see
the diversity within diversity.
Not everyone who comes
here is a PhD student
who had the highest test scores
in all of China or India.
Some of them are people
coming from very different
circumstances.
There are people whose
are, or whose parents were,
boat people, and who
have just struggles
that we can't even imagine.
If we can't imagine
them, we're not
likely to show very
much empathy for them.
But what's most pernicious
is the model minority
myth allows all of us,
including Asian-Americans who
tout the tiger mom, and
so on, to say to them,
you're not our concern.
You're not one of us.
And we don't see that disparity.
It's masked because of the
significant numbers of Chinese
and South Asians,
Koreans as well,
that swamps all these numbers.
Because the Southeast Asians are
a much smaller absolute number,
and much smaller proportion.
So thank you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Affirmative
action and civil rights
bills were introduced
to help, basically,
minorities, for example,
African-Americans and Latinos.
Among my friends, circle of
my friends, especially Asian
friends, it seems that
points are very divided
towards affirmative action.
The majority of my friends do
not like affirmative action,
because they say, hey,
look at our SAT scores.
Our kids are scoring so well.
Average Asian students score 150
points more than other races.
So race should not
be an issue, be
a factor in college admissions.
But then, affirmative
action is supposed
to help minority groups, and
Asian being one small minority
group.
So what do you think is the
correct political stance Asians
should take as a group?
FRANK H. WU: So we
have five minutes left.
This subject is far
too complicated.
Google has been a
very generous host.
I'd be delighted to come back to
speak specifically about that.
I'll just make three very quick
points, just very briefly.
Number one, I'm on
the side of everyone
who wants to see a better
life for themselves
or for their children.
Asian-American
parents and families
who want to pursue
higher ed, who
want their kids to go
to the best college,
deserve our support.
They want nothing different
from what any other family
of any background wants.
I want to be absolutely clear--
I'm on their side.
And I have zero doubt,
based on what I've seen,
that Asian-Americans face
bias in higher education.
I have no doubt about that--
first point.
Second point-- you were very
careful, and I commend you.
There is a big lie.
And people are encouraged
to believe this lie.
And I use the term
"big lie" advisedly.
The big lie is this--
Asian-Americans,
it is true, when
you look at the most highly
selective institutions,
have to score
higher than others.
But let me be very clear--
they score higher than whites.
They have to score
higher than whites.
What does this mean?
This means that
the real issue here
doesn't have to do
with affirmative action
for African-Americans.
It has to do with regular
racial discrimination in favor
of whites.
Why?
Because A, Asian-Americans score
higher on average than whites.
And B, there are many, many,
many, many, many, many, many,
many, many more whites
than blacks in the pool.
So however you measure
this, objectively, the bulk
of the effect, negative
effect for Asian-Americans,
comes from
competition where it's
weighted unfairly for whites.
In other words, it's not
about affirmative action.
So your friends who are angry,
they're right to be angry.
They should understand who
they out to be angry at.
So if you look at higher
education, legacy preferences--
if your father or mother,
usually father went
to the school--
result in admission rates
sometimes an order of magnitude
higher than in the
general applicant pool.
So understand how much a thumb
is being put on the scale
there.
Now, people point out
those individuals often
are qualified.
But understand, too, that
higher education admissions
at selective schools is
not about who's qualified
and who's not.
Everyone who gets
in is qualified.
It's about among the individuals
who are qualified, who gets in.
Because there's a
scarcity problem.
That's another issue.
We just don't have enough
seats to go around.
And Asian-Americans would
be adversely affected
no matter what.
Here's why-- Asian-Americans
apply to selective colleges
at 2x the rate of
other minority groups,
or all other racial
groups-- sorry,
I misspoke-- including whites.
What does this mean?
This means anything you do.
So let's say you
increase the class size.
So you decrease the class size.
It's going to have a
disproportionate effect
on people of Asian descent.
It's got nothing to do
with affirmative action,
preferences, merits, or any
program you have at any school
will affect Asian-Americans
in a massive way.
And there are also studies
that suggest something--
Asian-Americans value
prestigious brands much more
in higher education.
They place a huge premium
and are much less willing--
in a way-- so I'm
going say something
critical about Asian-Americans.
If you don't get
into Harvard but you
go to Princeton instead, I
really don't feel bad for you.
Princeton is a
perfectly fine school.
And arguably, Princeton is a
better school than Harvard.
Or I went to college
at Johns Hopkins.
It's in the top 10.
Do I lie awake at
night thinking,
oh, man, I didn't go to Harvard?
No, I don't lie
awake thinking that.
I was a fellow over at Stanford.
It all works out.
But the third point
is, the framing
of this whole argument,
affirmative action or not,
is the wrong framing.
The first thing we teach
people in law school
is if you're going to be
an effective advocate,
you have to know
what question to ask.
Because the person who
controls the question asked
has already determined
the answer to be given.
When we frame this as, should we
have affirmative action or not,
anyone who supports
diversity has already lost.
The real question is, how do
we make good on our ideals
in a practical way?
And for some people,
they don't care.
If the entering class at
Stanford or Berkeley has one
African-American in it,
and for some programs--
and remember, in
California, 1996,
voters abolished in the UC
system consideration of race.
It does not occur.
And immediately afterward,
and you can look up
all this data for many
different programs, law,
different graduate
schools, you had
zero or one African-American.
Not just African-Americans-- if
you look at Southeast Asians,
if you look at Berkeley
Law School, for example,
I think the year
after Prop 209 passed,
it had either zero
or one Filipino.
I'm not talking
about we should have
proportional
representation or quotas.
And I don't have a fancy
constitutional theory for this.
I'm just going to say
something that I believe.
You don't have to
believe as I believe.
I think if a law school has
zero African-Americans, that's
not good.
That's just-- as a society,
we can't have that outcome.
That is not an
acceptable outcome,
or if it has zero Filipinos.
The largest concentration of
Filipinos in North America
is in Daly City.
And if the institutions,
the public institutions
of higher education
in the Bay Area
enroll next to no Filipinos, we
ought to be worried about that.
One last question.
Yeah.
You have a question.
AUDIENCE: You've shared a
lot of insightful things
that even I didn't know.
I thought I'd heard all
these things before.
So how should we take
action in forums?
When do we talk?
Or is this kind of a topic which
is always smaller of importance
than the larger ones
that are present,
like physical violence,
or-- because you're
talking about subtext.
Someone [INAUDIBLE] hurt
you, less urgent, but still
important to talk about.
FRANK H. WU: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to tell one
last story in closing.
We're already at one and two--
I have two and a half minutes?
SPEAKER: It's OK.
FRANK H. WU: So when I was a
kid growing up, I was beaten up.
I often fought back.
I like to think I did pretty
well in the scrapes I got into.
Even today, even in San
Francisco, when I walk down
the street, sometimes
a kid comes up to me
and does the Ching
Chong, you know,
karate Kung Fu moves,
howling and hissing,
even if I'm wearing
a coat and tie.
They're pretty sure I've got
that black belt on underneath.
Here's something
interesting-- when I was a kid
on the playground during recess,
and all of these issues--
this is where they occur--
bullying on the
playground during recess
when you're seven years old.
And my classmates-- there's
a term now, frenemies--
they were sort of my friends.
That's what's most
troubling, because it's
one thing if it's
someone who hates you,
and you know they hate
you, and they do this.
But sometimes it's the
people you play with.
You think they're your
friends, but then it
turns out in a moment
when they're not thinking,
they call you a chink.
Or they say, not you.
We like you.
But they think of your
parents as chinks.
So it didn't happen
every day, but it
happened almost every day.
And what I would
say to the teacher
that yet again
this happened, you
know what they would say to me?
They would say, just tell
them, sticks and stones
will break my bones, but
words will never hurt me.
Any of you ever hear that, along
with "Chinese, Japanese, dirty
knees, what are these?"
And then people pull their
eyes back in the slant.
That still goes on today.
By most measurements,
bullying is
highest among either
Asian kids or Muslim kids.
Other groups don't
get bullied as much.
And the bullying
comes from all sides.
It can be from whites,
blacks, Hispanics.
It can even be
from other Asians.
So even as a kid, I
thought, you know,
the sticks and stones line--
I'm not persuaded by it.
There's something wrong
with it, for two reasons.
The first is-- and so I'm going
to slightly take issue with
what you said--
the words lead to the
sticks and stones.
So yes, the words
are almost trivial.
They're certainly trivial
to the person uttering them.
They're traumatic to the person
who hears them repeatedly.
But it falls on a spectrum.
When you look at hate
crimes like the killing
of Vincent Chin in
Detroit, my hometown--
I didn't know
Chin, but I grew up
a few miles from
where this happened--
in one sentence, 27-year-old
in 1982 bludgeoned to death
with a baseball bat by
autoworkers who blamed him
for the success of
Japanese car companies,
even though he was of
Chinese descent, not
Japanese, and American, not a
foreigner-- mistaken identity
twice over.
Wouldn't have been right if
they'd picked more precisely,
and killed someone
of Japanese descent
for representing
Tokyo and Toyota.
But the point of
this is what preceded
that bludgeoning death?
Chink, jap, nip.
And then they finally said,
it's because of you little
motherfuckers.
Pardon the language.
Because of you
little motherfuckers
that we're out of work.
Those words are fighting words.
They got people riled up.
Alcohol, testosterone,
hatred-- it all mixed together.
So my first concern is, yeah,
the words, they are just words.
But as we've seen recently,
tweets, memes, this all
has power.
This is the hatred on the
web, the sophisticated modern
version.
This is how people are primed
to go out and do this, even
ordinary people.
They're not bigots
through and through.
But they go to a rally,
a neo-Nazi rally.
They get all excited.
The Asians are taking over.
China is rising, and look
at all these Asian-Americans
at your school.
How come they get
all the goodies?
And those words stir people up.
The other reason this
sticks and stones retort
never persuaded me is, I'll
be honest, when you're a kid,
you suffer all sorts
of physical harm.
You fly off a swing set,
you knock your teeth out.
I actually did that.
You have high fevers.
You tumble down stairs,
you break your arm.
If you're a kid, and
you break your arm,
especially if you're a boy,
you've got street cred.
You've got a cast.
People sign the cast.
You're cool for six weeks
because you walk around
with that cast.
You recover.
You recover from physical harms
that adults couldn't take.
I look back on
that, and I think,
that's all right I knocked my
teeth out on the swing set.
That's a pretty good story.
I mean, who doesn't do
something like that as a kid?
It's rough and tumble.
But even now, if a car drives
away and someone shouts,
go back to where
you came from, I'll
tell you that packs a
wallop more than a punch.
It reduces me to nothing.
It says not just me, but all
of my kin, we don't belong,
that we have no rights.
So how do we respond?
I'm going to give you a
law professor's answer.
There is no one answer.
You don't respond the
same way at the workplace
or to your new girlfriend's
grandmother, who says, oh, gee,
you're taller than most Chinese.
You don't immediately
say, you're a bigot.
That's not an
appropriate response.
You have to calibrate
for the context.
It takes multiple strategies.
But it takes bridge building.
It takes working with others,
which requires acknowledging
that there is an issue.
Truth is, and this is
the last thing I'll say,
I've never gone hungry at night.
I recognize that I'm relatively
privileged, that the prejudice
I face, even though we don't
want to compare suffering,
because that contest
has no winners,
I'm not stereotyped as a thug
when I walk down the street.
The worst is these karate moves.
So it takes understanding
that this is all around us,
that even if you achieve the
highest level of success--
so I used to run a campus of
the University of California.
That's not small.
My mother was proud I
had the title Chancellor.
It sounds even
better in Mandarin.
And I would go out,
and I would fundraise.
I'd meet donors.
I'd meet alumni,
judges, lawyers.
I would see important people.
In a busy week, I might meet 100
strangers, shake their hands.
I can't tell you how many times,
not every day, but every month,
sometimes more than once a
month, someone would meet me,
and they'd be surprised.
They'd say, really,
you're the chancellor?
You're the dean?
They would look at my
card, and they'd say--
they would actually do
this-- they would say,
is this title right?
They just wouldn't
believe that I was
the CEO, that I was in charge.
They would just
tell me to my face,
oh, you mean you're
an associate dean?
I would say, no, no, I actually
am in charge of the place.
But here's the kicker--
I would usually be staffed by
somebody, fundraiser, or CFO,
general counsel,
sometimes students
would be out there with me.
But someone would be there.
I think of them as colleagues,
but they were always
junior to me.
They reported to me,
because I was the CEO.
Not once, never in
almost six years,
10,000 strangers I met, never
did anyone look at someone
who's a white male
and think, I'm sorry,
that's not what I want to say.
Not once anyone look at
anyone who is female or black
and think that they
were in charge.
They always understood they
were subordinate to me.
But more than once, a dozen
times, couple dozen times,
someone would look
at white males,
and when we were coming
in, and they were told,
you're going to meet
with the chancellor,
they would go over to the
white male subordinate to me
and shake their hand.
And then there would be
this awkward embarrassment,
when it would be
explained, no, no,
that's actually the
person staffing me.
Now, is that person
a racist, a sexist?
No, they're just
an ordinary person
who assumes if they're going to
meet the individual in charge,
it's going to be a white male.
So what did I learn from this?
I learned that all
women were presumed
to be subordinate to me.
That's not good.
That's just sexism.
And that essentially
anyone African-American
is assumed to be
subordinate to me.
But white men often,
not always, but often
were assumed to be my superior.
I was there just to
carry their bags.
So these issues arise.
And once you start
looking at them,
once you start realizing that
it's around us in the world,
you start to see that yes,
work twice as hard, study,
be successful.
But if you really
want to achieve--
not only for yourself, but for
our society, for a community--
the potential of this
nation, what it stands for,
what we are proud of, those
principles that we proclaim,
regrettably, there
are these moments,
even in the San
Francisco Bay Area,
even in the most
enlightened workplace, where
you have to catch yourself.
And you have to say,
excuse me, I think
I need to say something now.
And that's not easy.
That's why we have
sessions such as this.
And it's why it's so important
to stand up and speak out.
Those are my last words.
Stand up.
Speak out.
You'll be the better for it.
So will your community.
So will our nation.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]